hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today I'm going to be showing
you something you can do uh that only
roughly takes about 10 minutes um that
can earn you about 300K and you can do
it about every four hours or every day
whatever you want to do it's going to be
obviously flipping as per my name but
these are items you can do every day
doesn't really have any risk involved
with it you do need a little bit of
money to start with but beyond that
there's no requirements for this method
obviously and yeah let's jump right into
it okay let's get started so we're just
going to show you what I do every day
you can do it every 4 hours really but
um what you could do for a daily task
that can make you quite a bit of money
let's see how much I can make I have a
timer just to see roughly how long it
takes me in game to actually do and yeah
let's get started uh so we're going to
start with a potion uh I do this pretty
much every day it's really easy to do um
I'll explain how I do a bit later but
basically what we're going to be doing
is decanting
potions uh for those who have been here
a while you've definitely seen this
before but who haven't uh basically all
you're going to do
is um buy a bunch of three do potions
and deant them into four dose potions
it's really easy but I'll show you what
I'm doing so what I did is I bought and
sold one uh three dose potion and bought
a four dose potion and you have all the
prices
there uh so you're going to take the
four dose potion Times by
75 and that's going to give you a margin
relative to the three dose potions since
you're going to be decanting them into
the four dose potions uh that's how much
that is equivalent value anyway and then
we're going to take off what we're going
to be buying them for
2230 uh so we're going to make 152 coins
on each one of these 2,000 is the buying
limit how many you can buy every four
hours uh given this yeah I guess 305k
pretty decent actually uh so we'll go
ahead and buy the super energies for
sure so
and 2,000 red a little bit so that's
definitely the most complicated flip
we'll come back and show you how I
decant them in a minute um next up we're
going to do uh Zar scales everyone does
it but um you can do this every four
hours it's really easy just bit of money
uh so we're buying them for
143 and we're selling them for
132 um it's a bit higher than they
normally are at we're just going to put
them in for 140 cuz I know that's the
general price of them and and uh come
back here in a little bit if they
haven't bought uh next up is yeah let's
do lot
Rune so we bought it for
216 that's pretty high and bought it for
209 so put the L run in as
well perfect and L run has a limit of
10,000 as
well and uh perfect next uh I'm going to
do Bow strings whatever I'm not like
planning this out too much here it's
just items that are very highly traded
you can do every four hours and uh you
get a decent amount of profit from doing
them uh bought the bow string for 138
sold it for 132 that's great do that as
well
132 and has a rough limit of 10,000 I
[Music]
think uh next up we can do Rune arrows
are pretty good trade quite often cuz
they're used for Ping and sell quickly
116 is what we're buying them
for and 11 yeah that's pretty
good and another 10,000 of
these
oops and we got about six mil left what
else can we do uh blood runes work
pretty well
three GP on the blood run sure why
not spine it for
295 10,000 will be
that and um what else we got available
here uh nature runes very quick flip
very
easy buying them for
to for 6
269 not sure about that yet it's only
one GP which is fine um
but we'll maybe hold off for a better
item yeah death runes have three GP
margin do
those
287 and we only have
about we have like a mill left after
this uh so what's an item that we do for
under a mill uh energy potion works
pretty well
uh but I actually did try to do this
earlier and I had an issue actually
buying them for some
reason yeah that's not going to work
right now but um could do try the Super
Attack potion same as the first potion
we did here again we're going to buy the
three do potion and sell it as
well and then we're going to buy the
four do
potion so then we're going to take a
cash later here and we're going to take
the four do potion so the price is 949 *
75 and take off 659 which is what we'll
be buying the three dose potions for uh
so it has a 52 GP margin not too bad and
yeah we'll definitely do that so
660 we'll buy them
for
660 and
10,000 and yeah that's it guys I
just sorry
2,000 oh we don't have enough okay
uh we'll do,
1500 okay 660 in there we
go and actually all our blood runes
bought away so that's kind of nice we'll
just plop those in here in this clip why
not and we're selling those for 298 I
believe yeah so right right there we
just made 30k profit
pretty
easy and yeah so we'll come back when we
have bought all the stuff and we'll can
the potions but we can stop the timer
here that was just 6 minutes pretty much
and yeah come back when this stuff has
bought okay so we're just popping in
here for a minute uh almost everything
is sold but we do have the super energy
potions here uh we managed to get 19
.7k of them sorry or 19,00 and yeah just
if you didn't know so you take the
potions the three do potions yeah you
run down to this guy here you hit decant
and he will create all four dose potions
for you which is awesome just run back
here um so we're going to sell them but
we can just recheck the margin quickly
super energy fours and that's what we're
going to be selling them for uh so
319 and yeah that's it we'll come back
when everything has sold okay we're back
and we have sold everything really
didn't take too long probably just a
couple hours so uh we are going to claim
everything and see how much we made uh
the timer's at about 12 minutes so
whatever we'll call it 10: and yeah
let's hit the collect button hopefully
yeah we're back up to 20 mil uh we'll
just sell off the random stuff we still
have in our
inventory um we just were impatient so
we checked the margin a couple times but
um and yeah sell this off sell the vials
for maximum
profit and yeah let's go have a look how
much we actually made in boat 10 minutes
of actual game time we had to wait a
little bit of actual real lifetime but
you know that's not important so let's
see how much we made so we got 325k so
that's pretty decent 10 minutes a day
you can do this every 4 hours just put
these offer in for these basic items you
don't really need 20 mil to start with
but uh that's how much I needed for
these particular items but you can do it
with a lot of other ones these ones tend
to not change in price a lot um and the
decanting potion trick works quite well
and that's it guys I hope you enjoyed if
you're new to my channel hit that
subscribe button to stay up to date with
all my newest videos and yeah see you
guys in the next video